Thus far, I've given you a general idea of how an
individual site that hosts computation resources and handles
a whole bunch of incoming client requests may handle these incoming client
requests in terms of load management. This brings us to the DQ principle.
The server has all the data that is required
for dealing with incoming client queries. So this
the full data set, or DF if the
full data set, that is required for handling
any incoming queries to the server. Now clients
come in with their queries and we will call Q0 as the offered load to the
server, meaning this is the amount of requests
that are hitting the unit per server time.
Even though the offered load is still Q0, maybe the server
could only manage to serve a portion of this incoming requests. And
that portion of the incoming requests that is completed by
the server is Qc. These are the completed requests. We define the yield Q
as the ratio. Qc over Qo. That is the ratio
of completed requests to the offered load. So, Q
is going to be a fraction between zero and one.
Ideally you want it to be one so that
all the client requests are serviced, but if the server
is not able to deal with the offered load
entirely, then the yield is going to be less than
one. Now each query that is coming into the server
May require processing all of the data that's available in
the server to answer this particular query. For
instance, if there's a Google search and the
search requires looking at all the corpus of
data that the server has to answer the query,
then you want to look at the full data set DF. However, it may be that because
of either failures of some of the data servers or the load on the server, it is
only able to process the query using a portion of the total data set, Dv. Dv is
the available data. That is used in processing the
query, in that case the harvest D is defined
as the ratio Dv over Df. That is harvest
is defined as the ratio of the available data
to the full corpus of data. Again, this is
going to be a ratio between zero and one.
Ideally, you want to make sure that the harvest is
one, meaning that incoming requests is completely served with all
the data that it wants. Depending on the service I
can give you different examples. So for instance if the
incoming request is a search, you want to look at
the whole corpus of data that is available to you
to answer that search. But if you are not able
to do that and the server is only using a
portion of the full data in the harvest in terms of the quality of
the results that is being given out to a particular client is less than one.